- I think, uh, Odell
is probably the scariest.
- We've been saying this
for years.
- None of us liked to see
Champ walk in the room
when we were playing poker.
Champ's pockets were
deeper than the rest of us.
- Ohhhh!
♪♪♪
- "Simms and Lefkoe."
What is up? What is good?
- Yo, what up with you?
- Bam, bam, bam!
I feel good.
- [Laughing] Apparently.
- Heavy hitters.
- Oh, "bam bam bam."
- Champ Bailey's comin' up soon.
Awesome dude.
- The Champ is here!
- He scared you in practice, huh?
- Yes. He'd scare you, too,
if you could throw.
I'll tell you the best throw—
It was more of
a run after a throw.
- Right.
- Kenyan Drake.
- What? That was insane.
- The Miami Miracle.
I was watching
here in the office—
Omar, "House of Highlights" guy,
lost his mind.
Where were you when it happened?
- I was at NBC watching it at the time—
- Going nuts.
- Going nuts, yelling
cuz he kept going—
- Tony Dungy's like,
"Wow. Wow. Wow."
But we talked—
I looked in the camera last week
and said, "You're crazy
if you don't think the playoffs
are goin' through New England."
- Right.
- Then that happened—
- Yeah.
- And now you're crazy if the playoffs
aren't going through Kansas City.
- Right, right.
- They had that two-game lead.
That felt like
a huge shift in power.
Is that gonna change
the entire playoffs?
- I think it definitely increases
the chance of the Chiefs
getting to the Super Bowl
in the AFC.
I think that's what it does
more than anything.
I mean, one thing we've seen
with New England
if there's a flaw, and
there's not many flaws
with New England
they haven't won a road playoff
game since 2006.
Now, granted, they've played
some good teams on the road
whether that was
Peyton Manning's Colts
or those Denver Bronco defenses—
- Yeah.
- And dealing with that
in the Mile High Stadium.
But the big thing is, you get
New England outta New England.
New England's like
the old Yankee Stadium.
When you walk in there,
you're like
"The ghosts of Belichick
and Brady are haunting me"
and, "Can we overcome
this crowd?"
And because they understand
how good their team is
the crowd stays quiet,
and Brady can make
nine million checks
at the line of scrimmage.
That goes by the wayside—
- And they put, like
audio recording stuff
in your locker room.
- Well, now, you're saying that.
- And they cut off
your communication
in the third quarter.
- You're such
a conspiracy theorist.
- I love that Belichick and Brady
have ghosts
and they're still alive.
That's how good they are.
- That's how good they are.
- What's up? It's Baker Mayfield.
You're watching "Simms & Lefkoe"
on Bleacher Report.
- So we wanna put
our guest to work.
Champ Bailey. Top-three,
top-five corner all time?
- Damn. I think he's
in the top-five discussion.
I mean, I'm not just gonna go
out crazy and say top three.
- Hall of Famer?
- Hall of Famer.
- Hall of Famer. Get him in, get him in.
- Hands down.
- Come on, guys.
You can exaggerate a little.
- Only DB I ever
practiced against
that actually scared me
in practice.
- There's a lotta good wide
receivers in the league right now.
I wanna know
how you'd cover them.
First one: Tyreek Hill.
So, you're Tyreek Hill.
Step to the line.
- Oh, you know me.
I'm Tyreek Hill, all right.
- You're Tyreek Hill? OK.
- Yeah. You still
gonna get up there?
- Really?
- Absolutely.
I mean, we're both fast.
I won't do this every play,
but I gotta get in your face.
I gotta let you know I'm here.
- Right.
- I mean, that's my bread
and butter, bump-and-run.
Now, I'm not stupid.
- Right.
- This boy runs a 4.2,
maybe a 4.1
so I'm aware of that
before I play him.
So my idea of playing him
from the line of scrimmage
is I gotta stay
in front of him.
You hear this old cliche:
"Get your hands on him."
Man, forget that. It's not about
gettin' your hands on him.
It's about stayin'
in front of him
makin' it hard
for him to get there.
That's the easy one.
That's the one they want.
- And you're not gonna try
to jam him?
- Of course I'm gonna try
to jam him.
- OK, I thought
you weren't sure.
- No, the hands are secondary.
- I think you're crazy, Champ.
- The hands are secondary.
So I gotta stay on top of him.
If he wants to run
a 15-yard comeback, curl,
you can have that.
I'mma come down.
I'mma pound you all day.
- All right. I'm going time out–
- Right.
- Because I believe you've seen the film.
- Yeah.
- I think a lot of corners have thought
that with Tyreek Hill this year.
- Yeah.
- And that first–
- We're talking about me though, right?
- I know I'm talking about you.
- Set him straight!
- I know this–
- Just want to be clear.
but if he did open up on you and
it looked even faster than it was on film.
Are you coming out earlier? I'm just saying,
like, I haven't seen anyone in the NFL–
So you're saying that if my film study
didn't show the real speed or I didn't feel it
and now I'm surprised by–
- Yes. And you got out there
and he was faster than you
thought he was gonna be?
- And that happened before.
DeSean Jackson. You know, fast–
One of the fastest guys I've seen.
- Right.
- Probably fastest I've ever covered.
- He– he blew past me on the
first play and I'm chasing.
I'm like, "Oh my god, this guy's faster than I thought."
- Yeah.
- I played off him a little more than I wanted to but–
- Okay.
- At the same time, I still got up in
his face when I had the chance.
You know, it's just being aware
of what the situations are.
There's a lot of layers to it, man.
- Yes.
I could go on and on about–
- Let's do another one: Antonio Brown.
- OK.
- There's part of me
that believes
that if you saw Antonio Brown,
it's lockup status.
It's "I gotta get my hands on him
big-time." Super-physical.
Am I right?
- You're right.
I'mma tell you
why you're right.
Because film study tells me—
this is what I know because
I've played against him
I've seen him
throughout the years.
He has a hard time
with big, long corners.
- Right.
- Richard Sherman gives him hell.
- Hell.
- So I'm aware of that.
- And no one factors this into
the best wide receiver—
- Jalen Ramsey is givin' him hell.
- Give him hell, you know?
It's hard for him.
And why is it hard for him?
Because they stay in front
of him, they make it hard.
He can't run around him
he can't just wiggle
and just go.
The tape will tell you
everything. Tape doesn't lie.
- I agree.
- What about goin' toe-to-toe
with a Julio for that long?
Like, is that
physically demanding?
Like, are you exhausted more
after that game
than after a game
against Antonio Brown?
- You know, a guy like that,
he's bigger
so he's not gonna have
the same release
but he's stronger, so your feet
really play a role there
because if you're just standing
there with your arms out like this—
- Oh, you're getting tossed.
- He's just, you know, a la Brandon Marshall.
- Or he's gonna give
you the jerk-through.
- I mean, yeah.
These guys grab you.
They want you to grab 'em.
But I'll try to get
my hands on 'em
but it's really more
about my positioning.
You know, I just wanna make sure
that I have a strong foundation
because they'll throw you by,
they'll grab your helmet.
I mean, it doesn't matter.
Fitzgerald, he's the king of that.
He'll grab you, pull you.
- Right.
- And another thing you have to
worry about is blocking.
Those dudes block
their asses off.
- Of all the guys right now,
whether it's Odell, Julio
Keenan Allen, Antonio Brown,
DeAndre Hopkins, Tyreek Hill
which one are you goin'
"60 minutes—
I could get anything,
I could get everything
that's gonna cause me
to earn my paycheck the most?"
- Well, I think, uh, Odell
is probably the scariest
because his run after the catch
is superb.
I mean, his first step
There's really not a lot
of weaknesses in his game.
- Yeah.
- He can catch everything.
You know, his route
running is excellent.
- We've been saying this
for years.
- Oh, yeah?
- But people haven't believed us.
- Yeah, well, people
wanna hate on Odell.
- I get it. I mean,
he's a little flamboyant.
You know, he likes
the limelight, like to dance.
You know, so what?
- But he's still awesome.
- What does he do between the lines?
- Right, right.
- That's all that matters, right?
So, you know, that's why
people love to hate on T.O.
but T.O.'s one of the best ever.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, just, you know,
just watching his game
there's really not a lot
of weaknesses, plain and simple.
- Yeah.
- I love the fact that we got to
see how you play the guys.
The other aspect of defending
a wide receiver
the quarterback eyes.
- Mmhmm.
- We've had a few
secondary guys here—
Landon Collins,
Jamal Adams—
that kind of shared that staring
contest with the quarterback
and you're tryin'
to figure it out.
Is there one that pops
to your head right away
of, whether it's a Peyton
or a Brady or somebody
that game where
they either got you
or you got them really good?
- You know, uh,
Philip Rivers, probably.
One of those guys—he always
let you know when he got you.
You know, I hated him
for about two years.
- [Laughing]
- Great guy. Love him to death.
But he was just hard
to deal with
you know, because he would—
You could tell
he studied your weaknesses
because, you know,
he would find those moments
when you just weren't
paying attention.
And he knew he couldn't
attack me the whole game
but he had his moments where
he would just throw it in there
squeeze it in there,
and the guy was accurate.
The ball looks like
it's floating, but it's not.
- I feel like he would say
something, too.
- He would, yeah.
"Yeah, I got you right there."
Or, you know,
he'd come back and—
"You jumped that one.
Don't do that again."
Or something crazy like that.
It's, like, half the time
I don't know what he's saying
but I know he's just
talking trash and just—
You know, he's a competitive dude.
- Yeah.
- And I appreciate it more now
than I did then.
- You played with
Deion Sanders in D.C.
What was that year like
with him?
Like, what'd you learn from him,
just bein' around him?
- You know, it's not just him.
It was Darrell Green, too.
- Oh, man.
- So, I had Darrell Green
my rookie year—
- Holy cow.
- That's unbelievable.
- And then Deion comes in
and I got, OK,
two Hall of Famers.
They're already Hall of Famers
at that point.
- Right, right.
- So I'm thinking,
"OK, you  know
I got two guys
I can learn from."
First of all,
before he even got there
I'm worried if I'm gonna start.
But everybody made it clear
"Yeah, you're gonna start.
Of course you're gonna start."
- Of course you're gonna start.
- But I'm thinking, like
"These are two dudes
I look up to.
How do I start over them,
both of them?"
- Wow.
- In their prime, I'd have loved
to have seen them race—
all three of you, really.
That would've been a tight one.
- Ooh! I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Darrell was a track guy.
I was a track guy,
but I was a jumper
and Deion was a sprinter
as well, so that's hard.
I gotta say,
I gotta say Darrell
because he at least won
the Fastest Man contest.
- He won the Fastest Man
a few times.
- So I'll give him that.
- Yeah.
You'll give him that.
- So then what about you and Deion?
- You know,
maybe we're neck and neck.
You know,
I can't give him anything.
- I was gonna say, don't give it to him.
- Not on tape, not on tape.
- Don't give it to him.
- I was gonna say, don't give it to him.
- Not on tape, not on tape.
- Don't give it to him.
- Hall-of-Fame-worthy stories,
Simms has shared a lot from his career.
Beautiful 7, 8 years of NFL glory.
The poker games in Denver.
- [Laughing]
- We had fun.
- First of all, none of us liked to see
Champ walk in the room
when we were playing poker.
Like, we all loved Champ, but
Champ's pockets were
deeper than the rest of us, so–
You know, Champ–
- But I was the cheapest guy walkin' in there.
- He might have been the cheapest,
but he wasn't afraid to throw
a little money around every now and then.
- Every now and then.
- So he goes, "damn, I wanna buy him
out of this pot. I know he doesn't have crap."
- So he was a good bully.
- Yeah, he had big stacks of cash.
- That team with Denver, so who
would be in these poker rooms?
- Oh, man.
- Champ, Brandon Marshall,
LaMont Jordan—
- Scheffler.
- Tony Scheffler?
- Man, Tony Scheffler screwed me
out of $800 and left town
the last time we played.
- Really?
- Yeah. You hear that? I'm bringing
that up, Tony Scheffler.
- Should we go find him?
- I won $800 one night.
He—"Oh, well, I don't have
the money on me right now.
I'll bring by the check
in the next day or two."
- Real Lefkoe move.
And then he signed
with the Lions.
He signed with the Lions,
like, three days later.
I never saw him again.
What do you got
going on right now?
- Oh, well, you know, I invested
in this company, BW Health
and basically they make
these socks, Lasso Socks
and what they do,
they mimic ankle taping
and one thing every athlete
hates is taping their ankles.
- Yes.
- You know—
- It's the worst, isn't it?
- It's the worst.
- These things feel so good.
I wear 'em every day.
Got 'em on now.
And for an old guy
that doesn't run around anymore
I can only imagine
if I was young and playing
what these would do for me.
You wanna know more
about it, LassoGear.com
tell you everything
about the sock.
Backed by technology.
Great socks.
- Hey, what's up? This is
your boy Nate Burleson.
Yeah, the guy
with the best flow.
Out here in New York,
all the way from the West Coast.
I came to talk that talk, and
I say it with my chest, though.
Keep it locked right here
on "Simms & Lefkoe."
- Damn! That was good!
- Whoo!
- Nate Burleson. That's flowetry.
He's got a skill.
- Ooh, I like that.
You got a skill too. "Flowetry"
- I think I do, too. I'm gonna
challenge Nate one day.
I'm gonna go down
to "Good Morning Football"
and rap battle.
I'm feelin' pretty confident.
- I like it. It'd be good.
He's done a lot for your life.
I mean, he taught you
how to do some handshakes.
- He has. Thank you, Nate.
- He's upped your game.
- Chargers-Chiefs. Fantastic
"Thursday Night Football" game.
11-2, 10-3.
Are you expecting a shootout?
Will it live up to the billing?
- I think so.
- Cuz every Chiefs game
has lived up
to the billing this season.
- I know.
It's unbelievable
the way they play in general.
Thursday night,
I always favor the home team.
- True.
- But, yes, the shootout
I do think is just—
It's gonna happen in this game.
I don't see how
the Kansas City Chiefs
can match up
with all the receivers
on the Los Angeles Chargers
down the board.
At some point, there's gonna be
a mismatch issue.
I do think it stinks
that they don't have
a Melvin Gordon or maybe—
they're not gonna have Ekeler.
- We're really not sure
at this point.
- I know, so that's going to
hurt them a little bit
because they do like
to run the ball, play-action
but I still think this is
a high-scoring affair
and I expect the Chiefs
to come out on top, because—
- All right, well, hold on. We
have to toss to "Somebody & Lefkoe."
- OK, fine, let's toss
to "Somebody & Lefkoe."
- Because you know who's
a better picker than you?
- Nobody.
- No. Say his name.
- Who's his name?
What's his name? Allie?
- Allie.
- Allie. S--t.
- Let's go see what
Allie the Oracle has to say.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
- Ohh! What up?
- So, listen, I heard you.
You know my name.
- What up? You doin' all right?
- Yes, sir, Mr. Simms.
- Good to see you. Yes.
- Here. So what I did was—
- Just call me Chris.
You signed it.
- I autographed it for you.
- Thank you.
- It'll go in my shrine.
- Adam, how you doin'?
- Oh, man.
- You're the man.
- Legit shock.
- I don't know why
I didn't pick up on this,
because there's
three seats here, too.
- You didn't see that?
- I saw it, but I didn't ask.
- Take a seat, Allie. Man.
So you're a little surprised.
- I am.
I'm glad you came to see me
cuz I don't know
when I was gonna come see you.
- You said you were coming
to see me, so I figured
I'd come see you instead.
- I will eventually, I promise.
- I need to pay this man his money.
Why? Because he's 6-2.
- Ooh. Cash money.
Man.
- So here's another stack of cash,
and an—
That penny literally went into my shoe.
- Some change.
- I like it.
- And some change.
- Our man, Allie—
- Yeah.
- by being a part of Somebody & Lefkoe,
- Right.
- has made nearly $700 this football season.
- I counted it up myself
- Way to go.
- Did you?
- Yes.
I wanted to have an accurate number.
- All I want is some free Wint-O-Greens when I come.
Okay? That's all I'm asking for.
- Okay. No problem.
- Just to come on our show.
- Whatever you want. Come on by.
- Yep. Alright.
- You heard his analysis about Chiefs-Chargers,
cuz you were hiding behind stage,
which is awesome.
What have you been
thinking about this game?
Cuz it's the last
"Thursday Night Football"
game of the year,
so we wanted to make it special.
- I think, well,
listening to Mr. Simms—
- Don't listen to me too much.
- I agree it's gonna be
a shootout.
- Yeah.
I think it's gonna be, um,
a lot of scoring.
I looked at some of the stats.
Lamar Jackson, I think,
rushed for, like, 74 yards
and we know Philip Rivers
isn't gonna do—
- No, that's not happening.
- No, not their game.
- So, you eliminate that
I think, um—
What's the spread? Three?
- Three. Chiefs by three.
- Chiefs at home?
- Chiefs at home, favored by three.
- And they're still fighting
for home-field advantage, right?
- Yes, they are.
- Yes, they do.
- They gotta come out and play.
I like 'em.
I don't think they're gonna
let it be that close. Chiefs.
- I am a thousand percent
with Allie on this one.
- I am, too.
I'm ridin' with him, too.
I am. I like it.
- I was nervous before the year
that the
"Somebody & Lefkoe" bank
would be dwindling down,
and instead
mainly because of Allie,
we are at around $6,000.
We started at $5,000.
- Wow.
- Right.
- And Allie was
the huge part of that.
- You the man, dude.
- I appreciate that.
- Thanks for dealing with me
and some of my, you know—
- Oh, absolutely.
- Fun hatred towards you.
- No problem. I'm a fan.
- Thanks.
- Of your dad.
- Oh. Thanks.
- [Laughing]
- That's amazing.
- How dare you come on my show
and take a below-the-belt shot?
- I had to get you back.
- That's amazing.
- You've been tearin' me up.
- No, you're right.
- For Simms—
- Peace out, homies.
- For Allie—
- Yes, sir.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And we will holla, holla,
holla atcha later.
Enjoy the games.
- All right.
- Damn, Allie.
- Hell yeah, Allie.
- See you all next week.
- ♪ This will go right next to
thy Aaron Rodgers ♪
[laughing]
♪♪♪
We both like the song
"I've Been Working on the Railroad."
- [producer] What?
- Except we don't call it that, but that's
what the song is to me, always.
- What are you talking about?
- The, um–
♪ The eyes of Texas are upon you ♪
♪ All the livelong day ♪
- That's great. I like that.